the government asked for recommendations
from the nhs pay
review bodies waiting for an
announcement
that never came angry because it's
cowardice
they they could solve this today and
they just want
at lunchtime health minister helen
waitley was expected to reveal exactly
how much more money
the country's largest employer would be
able
to offer its workforce the people who
actually have the power
to change the situation they've done
nothing
in the evening the government announced
it had accepted the three percent
rise recommended by the independent nhs
pay review body
for nurses like gemma and other nhs
staff
but she says that amounts to just eight
pounds per week
extra for her they need to pay us what
we need
to live it's fair wage we're not saying
we expect anything on toward or expect
more than anyone else
we just expect to be paid enough to live
i'm i'm
really lucky i haven't had to go and
join a queue at the food bank
but a lot of my colleagues have and
still are
the health secretary says the decision
to raise pay by
three percent back dated to april
recognizes the contribution made by
health workers during the pandemic
i'm sure that this pay rise will make a
real difference to people's lives
not only putting more money in their
pockets but showing them
how much we value and respect their
incredible contribution
to our nation but nursing unions argue
thousands of vacancies remain unfilled
and staff
are shattered industrial action is now
being considered
our nurses will now engage with us as a
royal college
we will go out to a consultative ballot
with our nurses and i will do what those
nurses
wish me to do on their behalf i will
walk alongside them
and i will listen to their voice because
clearly their voice wasn't heard by
by westminster today
nhs workers were moved by this
national outpouring of heartfelt
gratitude
but clapping is not enough
they say they deserve to be rewarded
with more
than just gestures ashish joshi sky news